Омікрон подорожує разом з вами?
Після альфи, гамми і дельти, тепер цей новий варіант коронавірусу на перших шпальтах світових ЗМІ.
Через нього чимало країн знову ввели жорсткі обмеження для подорожей.
Вони бояться, що новий варіант може бути навіть більш заразним, і вакцини слабше захищатимуть від нього.
Навіть у країнах з високим рівнем вакцинованого від кoвіду населення
починають зашкалювати показники інфікування.
Зараження коронавірусом виникає навіть попри вакцинацію.
Це непокоїть чимало людей і породжує нові чутки щодо неефективності щеплень.
Зараз я стаю дедалі невпевненішою, бо, здається, вакцинація не спрацювала.
Я не хочу робити третє щеплення, бо боюся, що доведеться вакцинуватися кожні півроку. А я не хочу.
Гадаю, це викликає у багатьох людей паніку, а також конфлікти між людьми та політиками.
На багато питань просто немає відповідей.
Наскільки ви довіряєте вакцинам?
Зовсім не довіряю. Я не відчуваю себе захищеною, дотримуюся дистанції і більше нікуди не ходжу.
Щеплення від коронавірусу високоефективні, але не на 100%.
Поширюється занепокоєння, що вакцини слабше захищають від омікрону на відміну від інших варіантів ковіду.
Достовірних даних поки немає, але такі виробники вакцин, як BioNTech-Pfizer і Moderna,
вже оголосили, що при необхідності адаптують свої препарати.
Також є дослідження, що вакцини від виробників BioNTech-Pfizer, Moderna і AstraZeneca
ефективні приблизно на 75% проти Delta -варіанту.
Аналогічна ситуація і з індійською COVAXIN.
Тобто ймовірність не підчепити коронавірус, маючи ці щеплення, - 75%.
Однак ризик захворіти все одного є. Це підтверджує світова статистика:
попри те, що в усьому світі повністю вакциновано понад три мільярди людей,
значна кількість все ще інфікуються ковідом.
Цифри доводять, що якщо порівняти людей вакцинованих, які все ж заразилися ковідом,
і невакцинованих, які також підхопили коронавірус - для останніх ризик інфікуватися приблизно вдесятеро вищий.
Однак нині ми маємо високий показник інфікувань, і це створює додаткові ризики для вакцинованих.
Як результат у групі ризику опинилися люди, організм яких
виробляє незначну кількість антитіл навіть попри зроблені щеплення, тобто захист у них послабився.
Імунна пам'ять вже є, але все одно існує ризик інфікуватися - ось це ми нині й спостерігаємо.
За інформацією РФ, російський Sputnik V також захищає на 83% від варіанту Delta.
Проте Росія поки не оприлюднила жодних наукових підтверджень цьому.
Водночас органи охорони здоров’я різних країн вважають вакцину Johnson & Johnson менш ефективною -
тут статистика показує багато повторних інфікувань у вакцинованих.
У низці країн людям, вакцинованим J&J, тепер рекомендовано зробити ревакцинацію іншим щепленням.
Схожа ситуація із Sinovac і Sinopharm - брак інформації щодо варіанту Delta свідчить про те,
що ці дві китайські вакцини менш ефективні проти найпоширенішого штаму коронавірусу.
Однією з причин збільшення повторних інфікувань у вакцинованих є і той факт,
що захист від щеплення з часом зменшується.
Через якийсь період імунна система не так добре пам’ятає зустріч з ковідом: тому кількість антитіл зменшується.
З точки зору тривалості ефективності, я думаю, що ми все ще вивчаємо це, розповідаючи про це.
Загалом приблизно через шість місяців після завершення вакцинації
люди мають більшу ймовірність повторно заразитися.
Ще одна причина, чому вакцина проти коронавірусу не дає повного захисту, полягає в супутніх захворюваннях.
Наприклад, діабет, рак або серцево-судинні хвороби.
Тому органи охорони здоров'я багатьох країн рекомендують третю,
бустерну вакцину насамперед людям з груп ризику і людям похилого віку.
Тому серед усіх цих дискусій навколо повторних інфікувань важливо пам'ятати,
що в багатьох європейських країнах, особливо в Німеччині, частка невакцинованих людей все ще надто висока,
і вони мають високий ризик зараження.
І це насправді причина того, чому ми бачимо нині високі показники зараження у Німеччині.
Якщо ми не зможемо зменшити частку невакцинованих, то взимку буде важко тримати вірус під контролем.
Дуже хочу ще раз наголосити, що всім є сенс подумати про щеплення.
Повторні інфікування у вакцинованих не означають провал кампанії щеплення.
Ми знаємо, що вакцини не гарантують абсолютної безпеки -
ще й тому, що вони були розроблені проти початкового вірусу, а не його варіантів.
Утім, доведено, що вакцини захищають від госпіталізації та важкого перебігу хвороби.
Враховуючи, що захист послаблюється з часом і не всі захищені однаково,
фахівці рекомендують робити бустерні дози.